hey guys i'm abby sharp welcome to
Abby's kitchen in today's video I'm
gonna be talking about something that
I've gotten a lot of requests for and
that is hypothyroidism interestingly I
myself was recently diagnosed with a low
t4 which also happened to me in my first
pregnancy as my hormones changed so I to
have a bit of a vested interest in this
topic and based on the number of
requests I received I know it's a very
common concern so in order to best
address hypothyroidism we're gonna be
talking about what the thyroid is what
happens when it's under active and the
plethora of health consequences that
could potentially be linked to this
condition we'll also be covering what is
considered to be a hypothyroid friendly
diet the potential impact of supplements
and how it can help you better manage
the symptoms of your hypothyroidism I'm
also going to be bringing in a colleague
of mine another fellow dietitian who
specializes in hypothyroidism to talk
more about hypothyroidism and things
like setpoint weight now if you don't
want any of the introductory information
on some of the causes of hypothyroidism
and want to skip right ahead to gettin
into you know your appetite weight
things like that check out the time
stamp right here now before we get
started I want to express that the
information in this video is for
entertainment and educational purposes
only and you should always speak to your
doctor and dietitian about your unique
healthcare needs
hypothyroidism is a serious condition
that there should be diagnosed by your
doctor and any dietary changes should be
overseen by your healthcare team okay
let's do this now what is the thyroid
and what does it do so our thyroid is a
small butterfly shaped gland located
near the base of our necks that helps to
maintain a healthy metabolism hormone
functions energy levels and much much
more
the thyroid does this by producing two
t3 and t4 and this process involves
taking iodine from the diet and
combining it with the amino acid
tyrosine our thyroid gland is closely
regulated by another small gland in our
brain called the pituitary gland the
pituitary gland produces
another really important hormone called
the thyroid stimulating hormone or TSH
which as the name alludes to stimulates
the production of thyroid hormones so
then what is hypothyroidism
hypothyroidism is the under production
of the thyroid hormones t3 and t4 aka an
underactive thyroid it is a well known
condition in Western society with about
one to two percent of the population
struggling with it now there are two
main categories that a hypothyroid
diagnosis can be grouped into there's
primary and they're secondary so primary
hypothyroidism is caused by a failure in
the function of our thyroid gland
whereas secondary hypothyroidism is most
commonly due to an inadequate amount of
TSH being released from our pituitary
gland so now that we know what
hypothyroidism is what are the symptoms
of hypothyroidism so some of the most
common symptoms of hypothyroidism
include tiredness mental slowness
impaired memory lethargy and
sluggishness feeling and tolerant to the
cold unexplained weight gain dry skin or
hair hair loss and irregularities with
bowel movements and menstrual cycles I
know that that sounds really scary but
it's important to note that the
appearance of symptoms will definitely
depend on the severity of the condition
most often problematic symptoms may not
actually impact one's daily life until
the condition is at a more severe level
in fact one City show that only 30% of
subclinical cases had any symptoms at
all so on that note what are the leading
causes of hypothyroidism so primary
hypothyroidism is most commonly caused
by an autoimmune disease which impacts
the thyroid like Hashimoto's for example
but it can also be influenced by other
diseases that predispose individuals to
an underactive thyroid like celiac
disease an inflamed thyroid aka
thyroiditis which can happen post partum
for example or due to a viral infection
iodine deficiencies or toxicities
external radiation therapy of the neck
or head various drugs disordered eating
habits
or an underdeveloped thyroid whereas
secondary hypothyroidism can be caused
by abnormalities or issues with the
pituitary gland or closely linked areas
of the brain like the hypothalamus now
let's look a little closer at some
specific diseases or conditions that
have evidence linking them to
hypothyroidism the first one that a lot
of you asked me about is Hashimoto's
disease hashimoto's is actually the
leading cause of hypothyroidism
affecting 5 percent of the American
population it is an autoimmune disorder
so your immune system is basically
attacking your thyroid the symptoms of
Hashimoto's are the same as those with
an underactive thyroid plus you may get
some swelling at the front of your
throat known as a goiter this disease is
hereditary and women are about eight
times more likely to develop it than men
and the most common diagnostic age range
is between 48 to 60 years old next let's
talk about celiac disease and gluten
sensitivities so celiac is another
autoimmune disease where basically an
individual has an immune response to
gluten and this affects about 1 percent
of Western populations research suggests
that there's about a four-fold greater
chance of hypothyroidism in people with
celiac disease than in the general
population now despite the whole
wellness community supporting everyone
and their mother going gluten-free to
manage their thyroid conditions there's
actually no evidence to suggest that
avoiding gluten will help those without
celiac or gluten intolerance the
research that supports a gluten-free
diet for the management of thyroid
disease is done with individuals who are
either diagnosed with actual celiac
disease bloon sensitivity or have
Hashimoto's meaning the results can
definitely not be relayed to the general
public who are free and clear of all of
these conditions so next let's talk
about the link between disordered eating
and hypothyroidism because this one I
got asked a lot about so disordered
eating as you likely know if you watch
my videos can show up in our lives in a
multitude of ways ranging from chronic
dieting to restrictive eating to actual
eating disorders oftentimes sort of
eating may result in serious nutritional
and caloric deficient
these putting the body at risk for
becoming actually malnourished it should
be no surprise that this malnourished
can lead to a plethora of health
consequences including hormonal
imbalances metabolic alterations and
weight fluctuations all of which impact
our thyroid it is well documented that
states of chronic starvation are
associated with changes in our thyroid
hormones and not always in the way that
we want we often see a decrease in both
t3 and t4 as well as Porteous age
performance so next I want to answer a
viewer question do plant-based diets
negatively affect the thyroid so I
wanted to get clear that veganism does
not cause hypothyroidism that's gotta be
made crystal clear in fact one study
found that following a vegan diet may
actually be associated with a protective
effect against hypothyroidism it should
be noted though that this study
concluded an insignificant relationship
and that more detailed research was
definitely needed but it's at least some
potential evidence that it might not
necessarily be a huge concern however I
do see why some individuals may make
this association and the reason for this
is that people who are following a
plant-based diet may be at heightened
risk for iodine deficiency which is a
common cause of primary hypothyroidism
yes I would say that an iodine
deficiency is pretty rare in developed
countries however in an unplanned diet
it may be a concern later we're gonna
talk about some of the main food sources
for nutrients like iodine but spoiler
alert most concentrated sources come
from seafood and dairy not plants again
I'm going to be covering all of this
super soon I will say however that while
most of these do show that many
plant-based followers can maintain a
healthy iodine status no problem if
there is an attention paid to balance in
the diet there can be a slightly
increased risk there are also other
essential nutrients for thyroid function
that may be a concern for those
following a plant-based diet mainly
because some of the most concentrated
sources of these nutrients
from animal foods so predominantly I'm
talking about iron b12 and zinc for this
reason it's really important to
supplement if you're not carefully
planning out your plant-based diet so of
course always speak to your healthcare
provider or registered dietitian about
the best supplements for you
another potential concern is that vegan
diet patterns often include increased
intake of certain foods that are known
to interact with a thyroid including soy
products and cruciferous vegetables now
moderation is definitely key and there
are definitely steps that can be taken
to increase the safety of consuming
these foods for thyroid health but I
will go into a lot more detail into this
soon so just hold tight
we'll get there I would say a bigger
concern with a vegan diet or really any
diet is the possibility that one might
not eat enough and as we've already
discussed under eating is associated
with thyroid concerns so if you're
transitioning to a vegan diet just make
sure that you're not under eating and
consider working with a registered
dietician to just map out which
nutrients maybe should be supplemented
ok so now we know all about some of the
conditions and diets that may
potentially be linked to an increased
risk of hypothyroidism let's take a
brief look at the next question that you
might be having how do I get diagnosed
so a proper diagnosis for hypothyroidism
can only be made with a medical
professional and it will involve
bloodwork to test your t4 t3 and TSH if
there's a suspicion of Hashimoto's you
might also get your antibodies tested
and it's possible your doctor will also
want to test for an iodine deficiency
which I want to be clear is pretty rare
in industrialized societies okay now
that we got those questions out of the
way let's move on to the juicy stuff how
does hypothyroidism affect your weight
and your appetite now as mentioned
previously the thyroid is key in
maintaining a healthy metabolism and
energy balance both of which closely
regulate our natural weight when thyroid
function is diminished
we someone see a corresponding decrease
in the body's metabolic rate and
sometimes this means that weight gain
can occur however statistically the
waking associated with hypothyroidism is
often pretty modest averaging about five
to ten pounds now I'm not suggesting
that people can't and don't gain more
than that if they have an underactive
thyroid as I know that your lived
experience may tell us something
completely different
but I'm just telling you what the
research says as we know by now weight
gain is very multifaceted and often
develops over a long period of time so
with this in mind it's important to be
aware of the fact that it's not uncommon
for people to struggle to lose a
significant amount of weight even after
being treated for their hypothyroidism
one study found that within two years
after hypothyroid treatment started just
over 50% of the study population was
able to lose weight and that this weight
loss was pretty moderate with an average
loss about 8.4 pounds another common
concern with hypothyroidism is the
impact on our appetite now something
that may surprise you is that a common
feature of an underactive thyroid is
actually a loss of appetite which may
kind of seem contradictory by the whole
weight gain situation however both these
changes are impacted by hormone
irregularities and it's common to see
your appetite increase again as a result
of treatment for hypothyroidism this has
100% been my experience early on in my
pregnancy I literally had no appetite at
all some days I look back at what I ate
and if I was busy it would only be like
a fraction of what I would normally eat
and yet some weeks the scale would still
be jumping up five pounds as somebody
with a generally healthy appetite like
you've seen my what I in the days the
lack of desire to eat totally freaked me
out and in fact this in combination with
like total exhaustion was the main clue
that I had in figuring out that
something wasn't really right thankfully
since starting on medication which I'll
talk about momentarily I
have definitely started to slowly feel
hungry or every single day I'm still
gaining weight obviously hello pregnancy
but it's not so drastic and fast now if
you're all nodding your head at the
weight gain struggles as I've gotten so
many comments from you guys about it
let's talk about treatment
and before I get into it again another
disclaimer that while diet is important
in most cases it cannot cure
hypothyroidism on its own so always work
with your health care provider and team
to ensure that you're getting the right
medications and supplements to get your
symptoms under control
so on that note let's talk the serious
stuff first medication for those people
living with hypothyroidism thyroid
hormone replacement therapy is the gold
standard for treatment the most common
and well researched medications are
really aimed at supplementing the body
with the thyroid hormone t4 so that way
the body still kind of needs to activate
it the common name for these medications
is levothyroxine and research has
supported that it can reverse symptoms
in the majority of hypothyroidism
patients now of course as is with most
medication there are some potential side
effects including increased appetite
weight loss irritability and anxiety
there are also several nutrients as well
as natural remedies which I'll discuss
later that have been found to interfere
with the absorption or bioavailability
of thyroid medications so you actually
want to space these out with your drugs
first on the list is calcium now
supplements or antacids containing
calcium can interfere with a lot of
thyroid medications
therefore it's often recommended that
you take any calcium containing
supplements at least four hours before
or after taking your thyroid medications
second is iron now similar to calcium
supplemental iron can also interfere
with the absorption and activity of
thyroid medications therefore again it's
also recommended that you take any iron
supplements outside of that four-hour
window of taking your thyroid meds
another nutrient that can interfere with
the medications absorption is fiber now
fiber is found in obviously a lot of
foods including whole grains vegetables
fruit etc meaning it can be hard to
avoid
therefore for most people it's often
recommended that thyroid medications be
taken bursting in the morning on an
empty stomach and then about 30 to 16
minutes later you can have your first
meal soy products are also known to
interact with
I roid hormone-replacement medications
therefore should also be consumed about
four hours outside of the window that
you're taking your meds and lastly
there's coffee now coffee can interfere
with the absorption of a lot of these
medications so it is suggested that your
first cup not be consumed until at least
a half an hour after taking your meds
all of this sounds really complicated
but most people deal with a lot of these
interactions without going crazy just by
taking their medication as soon as they
wake up and then waiting 30 to 60
minutes before eating and then taking
any of their other supplements at night
or later on in the day okay now let's
get into my bread and butter diet
starting with what to enjoy more often
let's start with the one that is the
most important iodine now iodine is an
essential element that is needed to
produce our thyroid hormones
therefore if we're deficient our body is
unable to make an adequate amount of the
thyroid hormones t3 and t4 therefore
increasing iodine intake through a
variety of foods may help us manage our
symptoms of hypothyroidism if the root
cause is an iodine deficiency however as
I mentioned before iodine supplements
are actually not usually recommended or
needed for people living in developed
countries this is because we can really
easily get the iodine that we need in
our diet through iodized table salt and
therefore becoming deficient in the
first place
is actually quite rare avoiding iodine
supplements is especially important if
iodine deficiency is not the cause of
your hypothyroidism as excess iodine can
either cause or worsen an underactive
thyroid so please do not self diagnose
and start taking iodine supplements
without supervision also it's important
to note that a lot of thyroid support
multivitamins out there actually contain
iodine so I always recommend taking just
the individual nutrients and supplements
that you need instead of blends if
you're really unsure of your unique
needs now the recommended daily intake
of iodine is about 150 micrograms for
adult males and females and this can
usually be met through foods like cheese
cows and soy milk
eggs yogurt iodized table salt saltwater
fish and shellfish seaweed products like
kelp doles and nori as well as things
like soy sauce to give this a little bit
more context a half of a teaspoon of
iodized salt contains a hundred percent
of the iodine that we need in a day well
a small cod fillet contains just under
70% a cup of milk offers just about 60%
and one egg has over 15% but like I said
my plant-based friends may just have to
make sure that they're using iodized
salt and adding seaweed products into
the rotation next I want to talk about
selenium now selenium is a powerful
antioxidant which protects our bodies
from cellular damage and is associated
with maintaining the health of our
thyroid selenium helps to maintain our
thyroid function in two different ways
one by activating our thyroid hormones
for use in the body and two by
protecting the gland from the oxidative
damage of free radicals through its
antioxidant properties if you recall
from before t4 needs to be activated
into its active form t3 in order to be
used in the body and selenium is
actually key in making that happen
therefore not only the selenium
deficiency hinder our thyroids ability
to synthesize thyroid hormones but it
also decreases its ability to activate
those hormones not good so the
recommended daily intake of selenium is
fifty five micrograms for most adults
selenium can be found in high
concentrations in foods like oysters and
other seafood Brazil nuts eggs and
sunflower seeds one single Brazil nut
for example offers us a hundred and
seventy-five percent of what we need in
the day so it's too bad I hate them so
much but one small halibut fillet does
contain over seventy percent quarter of
a can of oysters has both fifty percent
and a quarter cup of sunflower seeds
offers just over 50 percent
now the third nutrient that we're going
to talk about is zinc zinc is also
required for the synthesis and
activation of our thyroid hormones
making it essential for proper thyroid
function the recommended intake
Zink is about 8 to 11 milligrams per day
for adults now animal products are the
most concentrated sources of zinc but
some plant-based options like beans
fortified cereals and pumpkin seeds are
some plant-based alternatives to give
you some context 1/4 of a can of oysters
contains a staggering 610 percent of our
daily needs while 4 ounces of beef chuck
contains over 70% 3 ounces of pork loin
about 30% and a serving of baked beans
zinc fortified cereals or pumpkin seeds
contain just under 30%
now the next nutrient plays a very
similar role in our body as selenium and
zinc which is copper copper helps to
maintain thyroid function and research
has fee on that diminished copper levels
are closely linked to lower thyroid
hormone levels the recommended daily
intake for copper is about 900
micrograms for healthy adults similar to
other trace elements some of the richest
sources of copper are seafood and red
meats however copper is also found in
several plant-based sources like dark
chocolate potatoes mushrooms as well as
nuts and seeds so 3 ounces of beef liver
contains an astonishing 1013 percent of
our daily needs of copper while one
square of dark baking chocolate offers
85% one square of regular 85% dark
chocolate has about 60% and one way
potato can have up to 75%
now the next nutrient that is closely
linked to thyroid function is one that
is hugely important for maintaining our
overall health and that is b12 now b12
has been linked to healthy thyroid
function and is also needed for healthy
red blood cell development and the
avoidance of anemia which I'll talk more
about soon one said he found that
approximately 40 percent of patients
with an underactive thyroid were found
to have a deficiency in b12 the
recommended daily intake of vitamin b12
is 2.4 micrograms for healthy adults and
the most concentrated sources are animal
products and fortified plant-based foods
now three ounces of clamps for example
contains thirty-five hundred percent of
our daily needs three ounces of beef
liver has about 2946
sent and on a more modest but adequate
level one serving of fortified
nutritional yeast offers a hundred
percent and a cup of fortified
dairy-free milk contain 50% now moving
on to another essential nutrient for
thyroid health iron so iron is an
essential nutrient that performs a
multitude of vital functions in the body
the main one being that it's responsible
for carrying oxygen through the body to
our tissues once that he found that 43%
of people diagnosed with clinical
hypothyroidism were also actually anemic
so the recommended daily intake of iron
for healthy adults is about 8 milligrams
for men and 18 milligrams for women but
this number increases when of course
anemia is present so while it is often
individualized the average recommended
dose for supplemental iron for dealing
with mild anemia is a hundred and twenty
milligrams per day now iron is found in
many different high-protein foods such
as red meat seafood and a variety of
plant-based sources one serving of iron
fortified cereals contains about a
hundred percent of the daily value for
healthy adults while three ounces of
beef liver offers twenty percent of
women's needs and fifty percent of men's
five muscles have sixty percent of
women's needs and twenty-eight percent
of men's and have a cup of cooked black
beans chickpeas or kidney beans offer
just over 10 percent of women's needs
and 24 percent of men's finally I want
to talk about tyrosine now we naturally
produce tyrosine in our bodies if we
have enough of its precursor
phenylalanine now tyrosine does play an
essential role in our thyroid health as
is the building blocks for our thyroid
hormones
however supplementing with tyrosine
could quickly elevate these hormones
above healthy ranges and therefore
supplementation would not be readily
recommended for everyone especially in
combination with thyroid medications
instead including a variety of protein
rich foods in your diet will help with
your overall balance and intake of
tyrosine as well as its precursor
phenylalanine so you can find this amino
acid in foods like beef pork salmon
chicken toe
phoo milk beans and lentils nuts and
seeds a six ounce portion of beefsteak
offers 264 percent of what the average
person would need for tyrosine in a day
while a medium salmon filet offers 248
percent a half a cup of firm tofu has 93
percent and two ounces of pumpkin seeds
contains 74 percent now let's take a
look at some foods that are commonly
recommended to avoid or reduce for those
with hypothyroidism and what the
research actually says starting with boi
Trojans now fun little factoid the term
boy Trojan actually comes from the word
Gator which is another name for the
enlarged thyroid gland yes you can bust
that little factoid out at your next
dinner party if we ever get to have a
dinner party anyways
Gorgons are compounds that are found in
a variety of foods with some research
suggesting that they may interfere with
thyroid function by interfering with the
uptake of iodine but this is really only
concern if there's already a thyroid
dysfunction an iodine deficiency and or
the foods containing these compounds are
consumed in excess so common boy Trojans
can be separated into five different
main categories cruciferous vegetables
like broccoli Brussels sprouts cabbage
cauliflower collard greens kale radishes
and turnips soy based foods like tofu
tempeh edamame and soy milk certain
fruits like apricots cherries peaches
plums and strawberries certain starchy
foods like millet sweet potato and
tapioca and some beverages like coffee
green tea and red wine now while a lot
of sketchy wellness diets will tell you
to never have a Brussels sprout again I
don't believe it needs to be so extreme
there are ways to continue incorporating
most of these Gorgons in your diet in a
safe and healthy way first of all some
research suggests that cooking or
steaming your cruciferous vegetables for
example has been found to kind of
denature much of their goitrogenic
effect rendering them much more safe for
consumption one said he found that
eating three to four serving
of cooked cruciferous vegetables per
week had little to no effect on thyroid
function assuming of course that iodine
levels were adequate this means you can
continue to consume your favorite
cruciferous vegetable may be a better
option to avoid any adverse effects when
consuming moderate levels of soy based
foods in conjunction with normal iodine
levels it has also been reported that
there really is no reason for concern
however if there is an issue with
supplementing with soy phytoestrogens
where it was found that there was a
three-fold increased risk of developing
hypothyroidism when doing so therefore
eating soy products in moderation like a
few times a week does not seem to be a
cause of concern if you're not iodine
deficient but supplementation should
likely be avoided now the goitrogens
that are commonly found in foods like
fruits grains nuts wine coffee and tea
are commonly referred to as flavonoid
antioxidants while there has been
research done that has shown that
flavonoids may result in anti-thyroid
effects these results have only
seemingly be found in labs not actual
humans so while food is likely safe
similar to what we said about soy
supplementation with flavonoids has been
strongly tied to anti-thyroid and going
through genic activities so avoiding
adding supplements to your diet may be a
good idea being that there's no strong
research to encourage people to
completely avoid these kinds of foods I
would say that enjoying them in
moderation should not be linked to any
adverse effects again if a person has
not been diagnosed with an iodine
deficiency however there are two
exceptions to this and that is with
millet and alcohol studies have found
that millet and alcohol can suppress
thyroid function even when an iodine
deficiency is not present
therefore choosing an alternative green
to millet is recommended so like quinoa
or oats or rice and of course enjoying
alcohol in moderation
I know the alcohol thing kind of sucks
but overall I don't think that following
a hypothyroid friendly diet really needs
to be that restrictive in fact following
restrictive
it's with an underactive thyroid is
definitely not recommended despite many
of them being promoted as beneficial for
thyroid health one of these diets is the
ketogenic diet so let's talk about that
for a hot minute the keto diet as you
likely know is a high fat low carb diet
keto changes how our body uses its
energy stores to run off of ketones
instead of glucose and therefore it
ultimately alters our metabolic state
the metabolic state our body's function
in when we're in ketosis closely
resembles a state of starvation which
some research suggests may be really
hard on our thyroid therefore it's often
been assumed that following a strict
keto diet for a prolonged period of time
is just not recommended 1 2017 study
Ashley the first-ever study to look at
the keto diet and thyroid function
looked at epileptic children who are
following a strict keto diet in order to
control their seizures and they want to
know how their thyroid hormones were
being affected they found that after
just six months 17 percent of the
patients developed hypothyroidism
signaling a significant correlation
between the keto diet and thyroid
function decline obviously more research
is still needed in this area to be able
to generate clear guidelines and
recommendations surrounding adults
specifically without epilepsy and/or
with thyroid dysfunction but for now I
know it's tempting because of the
association between hypothyroidism and
weight gain but I would not recommend
trying the keto diet to manage your
hypothyroidism until better and more
conclusive research is being done
I would rather you focus on adding foods
and nutrients to your diet to support
your thyroid rather than focus on taking
them away and cutting extreme amounts of
calories and lastly moving on let's
briefly touch on some natural
supplements while I am all for
supporting and as natural as possible
lifestyle I think a warning should be
issued here that these natural remedies
have much less research backing them up
and have even been found to interact
with a variety of medications therefore
if you're opting for the natural
to deal with your hypothyroidism I would
strongly urge you to seek out a medical
professional who's gonna make sure that
you're not taking any supplements that
are going to interfere with your
medication or diet so there are several
popularized natural remedies that claim
to have thyroid stimulating effects
these include ashwagandha which has the
most evidence to back up the claims
coleus go-to Kula and Google I mean I
don't know if I'm saying any of those
things right because I feel like I'm
talking baby gibberish but anyways the
first ashwagandha is also commonly known
as Indian jinx Inc or winter berry this
is a natural herb that has long Dean
believed to help the body manage stress
but has also gained recent popularity as
a potential alternative treatment for
managing hypothyroidism this claim was
supported by one study which found that
supplementing with 600 milligrams of
this herb daily significantly improved
thyroid hormone levels and TSH within
eight weeks
that's pretty promising however since
this herb is also linked to decrease
stress levels it's unknown if the
findings are result of the Asha ganda
directly improving thyroid function or
decreasing stress levels through its
proposed anti stress properties chronic
stress is known to increase cortisol
levels which does in turn negatively
impact our thyroid so it is possible
that the impact really is on the stress
relieving properties of the herb of
course we definitely need a lot more
research to confirm all of this so I'll
be keeping my eye out for that now the
second natural remedy coleus is also
referred to as forskolin which I know
sounds like foreskin and isn't very nice
anyways this is a natural herb that is
claimed to increase thyroid function
however the research is definitely very
limited and what does exist is pretty
outdated I mean we're talking 1984 so
honestly no strong recommendations that
can be made then we have go to Akula so
this is a leaf that has proposed thyroid
health benefits due to properties that
apparently stimulate the thyroid gland
to produce more t4 but again there's
minimal evidence existing to really
support this claim so hard to make
really good recommendations lastly you
may have heard of Google as a potential
hypothyroid alternative medication this
herbal remedy comes from a tree and is
supposed to increase the conversion of
t4 to t3 similar to the previous two
though there's limited scientific
evidence to really support any of these
claims I do want to close with a
statement that I found in one study
where they specifically disclaimed we
recommend against the use of dietary
supplements
nutriceuticals or other over-the-counter
products as a means of treating
hypothyroidism we particularly caution
against the use of pharmacological doses
of iodine because of the risk of
thyrotoxicosis and hypothyroidism in
those with intact thyroid glands
susceptible to becoming further
dysregulated because of underlying
thyroid pathology so basically stick to
what you're most comfortable with
but please do so no matter what under
the guidance of your health care team
now to bring some practice-based
evidence to the picture I have brought
in my colleague fellow dietician Lacey
Dunn who specializes in hypothyroidism
but thank you so much Lacey for joining
me thank you so much for having me on
it's an honor to get to chat with you
and of course your listeners as well so
I had some big questions come in from my
viewers and the first one was how does
hypothyroidism alter a person's setpoint
wait yeah that's a great question so
when we're looking at hypothyroidism
essentially what happens is your thyroid
is the master of your own body think of
like the mitochondria is the powerhouse
of the cell your thyroid is the
powerhouse of your body and your
metabolism so if you do if you have
hypothyroidism essentially what happens
is you have drops in what's called your
t4 and your t3 and what happens with
this is you have down regulation of your
hormones your metabolism you are not
able to maintain your weight at the same
amount of calories that you were before
so essentially it down regulates your
metabolism and totally screws off and
throws off your setpoint yeah and in
your experience what needs to happen for
people who you know to be able to see
their weight come back down to or come
up whenever way this is going to their
pre diagnosis set point so the most
important things when it comes down to
getting back to that set point or
maintaining it is first looking at well
what is your overall diet look like so
you're looking at making sure you get
those adequate micronutrients in your
diet that are involved in your thyroid
both the creation of your thyroid as
well as the conversion of your thyroid
so you have t4 which is inactive thyroid
hormone that converts to t3 that's
active hormone and you need that
conversion in order to be able to
utilize that thyroid hormone so you're
looking at things like iron iodide zinc
vitamin C B vitamins making sure you get
all your central me you know acids
you're also looking at making sure
you're managing sleep because if you are
not getting proper sleep then your
thyroid is not gonna be happy your
hormones are not gonna be happy making
sure you're balancing your blood sugar
very very important because if you're
not balancing that blood sugar that
thyroid is not going to be happy and
your adrenals are not and your adrenals
or your best friend when it comes to
your thyroid health also stress
reduction I kid you not this is what a
lot of people they do not focus on
stress reduction self-care the best
things that you can do to help your
setpoint your health and your happiness
and then you're also looking at making
sure you get all healthy good healthy
fats and mega three fatty acids as well
as a good amount of your vegetable and
fruit and take and a good colorful
variety there so overall just try and
focus on what nourishes you mind body
and soul I think that's great advice and
and so any additional non diet tips for
people out there who are struggling with
the weight gain associated with
hypothyroidism I would say the most
important thing is to give yourself some
grace and some love and know that that
hypothyroidism diagnosis the weight gain
that you might be having or inability to
lose weight it's not your body hating
you it's not anything you did to
yourself that is your body that's a fire
alarm in your body asking for help
so be willing to give it some love give
it some grace and understand and know
that your body
go back to its that point and you'll be
able to reach those goals that whatever
goals you have and feel better once your
body is in a place of healing and it is
no longer in a place of complete
destruction and chaos yeah I think
that's great advice and and for those
who are experiencing changes in hunger
which we know is a common side effect of
hypothyroidism how do you suggest
honoring that appetite and that those
hunger changes while still meeting
nutritional needs so I mean this can go
either way whether for example somebody
loses their appetite when they've been
diagnosed with hypothyroidism do you
suggest kind of manual eating on a
schedule regardless of maybe not feeling
hunger and then if somebody gets goes on
medication and their appetite increases
suddenly should people be responding by
eating more even if they your goal is to
lose weight yeah I'm so glad you
mentioned this because I know a lot of
people they have a struggle with it and
is then essentially it's two different
scenarios so if you're struggling with
not being able to eat then it's very
important as tough as it is it's very
important to give yourself a consistent
schedule because what you really need to
do is you need to balance your blood
sugar and you don't want to be going 5
to 6 hours without eating because that
is going to spike up cortisol which is
not good for your thyroid and of course
nobody wants you hangry either and moody
so it does mean sometimes having a
consistent meal schedule making sure
you're getting in a protein source with
each meal and snack sometimes that is
the case but when it comes down to
overeating and having to being too
hungry then that is that is another
tough scenario because then you're like
oh I'm really hungry but I'm gaining
weight or I can't maintain my current
weight and in reality it comes down to
okay well what can you do then to help
satisfy that hunger because you don't
want to push away hunger that hunger is
again like a far-off fire alarm and so
looking at your diet getting in complex
carbohydrates proteins with each meal
filling up on good fiber vegetables
fruits that's really important so I like
to look at food volume first and don't
try and dissipate that hunger it just
kind of monitor what can nourish you
what is you up what makes you feel good
yeah I think that's some really great
information for everyone that is
watching that is being struggling with
their own hypothyroidism diagnosis so
thank you again so much Laci for all of
your information for those who are
interested I'll be leaving some links
below to Lacey's social and web site in
case you're looking for some one-on-one
support and Lacey tell us you've got a
great resource that people can access I
do so if anybody wants a free no BS
guide to hypothyroidism in Hashimoto's
you can just check it out on my website
it includes things like what is
hypothyroidism and Hashimoto's the
differences labs to test symptoms
essential nutrients supplements that can
help you name it so free guide just
checking on my website lebu thanks again
have a great one you're so welcome thank
you
a big thank you again to Laci I'm going
to be leaving some links below to her
social and website for some one-on-one
support now bottom line I know it's
scary to get any kind of diagnosis never
mind one that may require lifelong
treatment and that impacts your
metabolism energy levels and body weight
the good news is that the roid or mone
replacement therapy has proven to
improve thyroid function and reverse
symptoms in the majority of patients
with only 12 percent reporting ongoing
symptoms of hypothyroidism now if you
feel like you may be dealing with some
of the side effects of hypothyroidism I
would urge you to reach out to a health
care professional like a doctor or a
dietitian for some extra guidance and on
that note folks that is all we have for
today I hope this video was in laning
and that it was helpful if you have any
comments I would love to know if there's
any other kind of medical conditions
that you want me to cover from a dietary
perspective don't forget to give this
video the thumbs up subscribe to the
channel and I will see you next time on
Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]